beaucoup de martinique et pensent comme
moi beaucoup de martinique elles pensent
comme moi c'est à dire qu'un à marie
c'est pour répondre à votre deuxième
question
alors qu'est ce que je fais mais d'abord
non pas pas en tout cas d'un coq or je
pète dans le campement je veux pas être
dans le camp par contre je vais être sur
le fond je veux être sur le fond c'est
pour ça que je suis dans je travaille
nous travaillons je travaille sur le
fond
ce travail sur un certain nombre de
dossiers je travaille à essayer de faire
en sorte que la collectivité fonctionne
mieux et je travaille je souhaite que
des hommes puissent se rassembler par
les ensembles s'engueuler quelquefois
s'engueuler mais construire ensemble
travailler ensemble c'est ce que je fais
c'est pour ça que je suis devant vous
aujourd'hui pour clarifier un certain
nombre de choses
demain vous allez voir que l'ignorer va
se passer à peu près bien ne se passera
pas si mal que ça oui il faut il ya des
choses à arranger où il faut qu'on
arrive à faire mieux mais il faut qu'on
arrive à travailler ensemble
c'est ce que je veux moi je veux qu'on
travaille et qu'on travaille ensemble il
sait pons en cela que je disais que il y
à une crise faut pas le cacher il faut
qu'on arrive à la résoudre ensemble
il faut pas que certains jouent d'une
espèce de comme si c'était des vierges
effarouchées mais en même temps on en
parle tout en en parlant et en en
parlant pas non non non il ya un
problème il faut qu'on le met à plat il
faut qu' il faut que les 6 et des
problèmes d'hommes que ça que ça ce que
ça se règle entre hommes entre 10 mai où
entre hommes et femmes
et puis si ce sont des problèmes je
dirais de fonds il faut qu on les aborde
dans dans une discussion libre et qu'on
essaie de trouver un point d'accord si
on trouve pas le point d'accord il faut
qu'on s'y et puis au bout d'un moment
c'est la démocratie 1
mais moi je crois que tout ça c'est
normal je parte je veux pas minimiser la
crise
alors vous peut-être que mon propos il
ya une crise il ya une crise elles
reprennent vient de quoi de pointe de
personnes sans doute peut-être une crise
de succession qui s'ouvre un peu trop
tôt peut-être mais c'est pas mon
problème ça quand je dis que c'est pas
que c'est pas que je dise qu'il ya qu'il
n'y a pas de problème la vie est faite
de ça je dis simplement qu'il faut se
mettre autour d'une table et travailler
et construire ensemble et que je ne
crois pas que ce soit insurmontable
pense pas que ce soit de la naïveté
on verra si ici les choses me donne
raison ou tort